das matterhorn wahrzeichen und symbol
der schweiz
auch stefan sigrist fühlt sich immer
wieder von seinem gipfel angezogen um
wie hier zum beispiel die landschaft mit
einer 3d kamera zu filmen
und jedes mal freut er sich auch wieder
zum fuß des tages zurückzukehren
interessante grad anstiegen
auch wände auch eine felsen sicht so gut
dass das matterhorn ist wohl auch der
meistfotografierte berg der welt
fotografen wie matthias haugg walder
oder stefan schlumpf kommen regelmäßig
hierher
sie finden immer wieder neue spannende
motive rund um den 4000
martin ist ein sehr schöner berg war für
mich sehr symmetrisch darstellt und das
zweite was ein einziger gemacht oder
sich auch sehr für ein bild sie ihre
eigene zeit weil er alleine steht
es ist natürlich spannend dass von unten
zu fotografieren aber viel spannender
ist natürlich dann wenn man auf dem
gipfel steht und für mich hat das
smartphone ins wiener spezielle
bedeutung natürlich aufgrund meiner
vorfahren die beiden erstbesteigung
dabei waren sein ur ur urgroßvater war
peter hauk weiter
ein bergführer der gemeinsam mit seinem
sohn den engländer edward whymper zum
gipfel führte das museum von zermatt
dokumentiert die erstbesteigung sowie
auf diese nachgestellten film erreichten
sieben bergsteiger vor 150 jahren
erfolgreich den gipfel
doch dann abstieg riss das seil und vier
menschen verunglückten kern des
matterhorn mythos ist ein seil um das
sich seither spekulationen ranken
nur die beiden top walder und edward
whymper überlebten
der brite schrieb einen roman über die
besteigung und stilisierte sich zum
helden
matthias haug weiter stellt zum jubiläum
erstmals auch briefe und dokumente aus
die er gemeinsam mit seinem corsa josef
haug walder und dessen sohn david
analysiert hat sie dokumentieren die
erstbegehung aus dem blickwinkel ihrer
vorfahren dass die gold wirklich noch
die möglichkeit erhalten haben
ihre version der geschichte zu schinden
ja es gab verschiedene theorien eben
weder das alter schnitten den braves
zuschnitten die dokumente aus dem leben
von vater und sohn toggweiler lassen ein
ganz neues bild von der erstbesteigung
des matterhorns entstehen das wird von
untersuchungen gestützt die alpinisten
direkt am unglücksort in der wand des
matterhorns durchgeführt haben
jetzt haben sie sich zusammengesetzt zu
einer seilschaft steht dann hoch bis auf
das letzte eis fällt kurz vor dem gipfel
und jetzt schneidet sich der winter vom
seil das seil durch dass er alle noch
überholen kann
und als erster offen gibt steht dass er
muss dass muss man sich auch mal zu
gemüte wen wer egoistisch der gehandelt
hat das nur dürftig gepflegte seil riss
beim abstieg doch die tragödie
motivierte von nun an immer mehr
menschen sich mit dem berg zu messen
zum jubiläum wird die route nachts
beleuchtet und auf 2600 meter höhe ein
theaterstück inszeniert wenn matterhorn
story versucht die geschichte der
erstbegehung authentisch zu erzählen
josef und david auch weiter übernehmen
dabei die rollen ihrer vorfahren als
bergführer
doch es geht ihnen dabei um mehr als nur
darum einen mythos zu demontieren
die leute wissen von mythen von drees
besteigung lösen werden
das motto das natürlich von
anziehungspunkt und das ist auch für uns
diese wohnen ist das von jedem tag eine
andere ansicht dass sie dem rathauses
wirksamen das ist ein eingriff drohten
ich denke dass dieser weg auch ohne
diese geschichte sehr viel zu bieten hat
mit seinen alleine steht und verfolgen
das ist einzigartig und nur schon wegen
dem nachzukommen
das matterhorn der einsame riese der
sich ständig wackelt sowie die
geschichten die sich um ihn ranken
er wird wahrscheinlich auch in den
nächsten 150 jahre nicht aufhören sich
immer wieder in neuem licht zu
präsentieren